So let's take a look specifically at the problem of
3-colorability. Can a given graph G
be colored with three colors.
So is this question in NP? Yes
How do we know that it's in NP?
Well we need to say two things:
We have to say that it has a short accepting certificate
and that it has a fast verification algorithm.
So the accepting certificate in this case
would be the actual coloring, the mapping of nodes
to the colors.
In this case, 0,1, and 2 or 1,2, and 3
How about the verification algorithm?
Well let's actually code that up in Python.
Alright, here's the skeleton of a program for
doing the coloring verification.
We're going to call an algorithm 'verify',
which is like the A that we had before.
We give it a graph, and a certificate,
which in this case is a mapping from nodes to colors,
and then the total number of colors K.
Here's an example of just building up one of these certificates
We've got nodes A-H, there's the connections
between all the different nodes,
we build a graph out of that, and then we build
a coloring by looking at a list that has nodes and different colors
0 through K-1. And for each one it just sticks
the color name into the corresponding node's id,
and then calls verify. And I do this twice
one with a coloring that's valid,
and one with a coloring that's invalid.
So write this verification algorithm
and we'll test it for you to see if it works.